the miracle of life a 40 week process
where you developed from a single cell
to a fully formed human baby all within
your mother's womb now imagine you were
born in an artificial womb a cutting
edge device perfectly replicating and
even improving on the environment of the
womb what if we were able to use these
artificial wombs to give birth and
brought babies into the world with
advanced technology how would we benefit
from artificial wombs can you see any
downsides and could this actually happen
in our lifetime this is what if and
here's what would happen if artificial
wombs could give birth you probably
don't remember your formative months in
the womb but it's safe to say you were
born from a good old-fashioned womb now
what if you were born from a
state-of-the-art artificial womb what
sort of benefits could you gain as a
little science baby well it could give a
fetus a fully optimized environment in
which to develop with a carefully
calculated formula for hormone and
nutrient needs and the fetus wouldn't be
exposed to any infectious diseases
artificial wombs would allow gay male
couples and single men the opportunity
to have a baby without the need for a
human surrogate they would also give
transgender women women born without a
uterus and those who have lost their
uterus due to medical conditions or
injuries a chance to have children but
how would this benefit the little tykes
themselves much of the research based
around the advancement of artificial
wombs is on the care of premature babies
in 2017 an experiment was performed by
fetal surgeon dr. Alan flake of the
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia
using an amniotic sac aka
a bio bag
this was used to provide lamb fetuses
placed in a sterile fluid with a protein
and nutrient-rich blood supply the
experiment simulated the 23rd to the
27th week of a human pregnancy after
they were removed from the bio bags the
Lambs grew up just as a traditionally
born lamb would ah on the other hand we
have to wonder if there could be any
downsides to using artificial wombs
would there be any cons if artificial
womb births were to become available and
affordable society would be bombarded by
debates ethics science technology
politics religion societal structure and
economics would all be stirred together
into one big punch bowl of non-stop
disputes
according to Detroit Medical Center
neonatologist dr. Sanjay Chawla an
artificial womb can't replace the
maternal influences of labor or the
placental influence of hormones and
biochemical signals on top of that if
artificial wombs were used the wrong way
or for the wrong reasons
we could be looking at a dystopian
nightmare
it could lead to things like baby
factories where children are
manufactured and sold a serious rift
could occur in our society as the number
of artificial womb children increases
the debate could include questions like
is it fair to apply the same standards
to kids who come from a mother's womb as
we do to those born from perfected
artificial wombs or what if something
goes wrong during the gestation period
and with the wealthy bypassed the risks
associated with natural wombs and just
use artificial ones it's definitely a
lot to think about but could this even
happen in our lifetime research is
already underway at the Eindhoven
University of Technology the university
is developing a way to provide babies
with artificial incubators
ones that could simulate the biological
conditions of a womb this way the babies
could receive nutrients and oxygen via
an artificial placenta connected to an
umbilical cord if all goes according to
plan the research will continue for five
years and then human babies will be
involved in the artificial womb
environment they will have everything
around them that they would have in a
natural womb whatever happens it's sure
to ruffle a few feathers but if we
develop this technology as a means to
help premature infants survive the idea
becomes a noble one
it makes you think about what else we
could create artificially maybe one day
we'll need to construct an artificial
planet to house humanity after we've
exhausted the earth but that's a story
for another what if
you